up one big question that has been coming
up is what will the impact be on the
november eighth election of third-party
candidates most notably gary johnson for
the libertarians and jill stein for the
Green Party we also have this this new
independent Republican Mormon candidate
who could make an impact in Utah I
talked about that yesterday so
nationally I already told you Hillary
Clinton ahead and what in the most
recent 19 poles of two-way races and in
the most recent 15 poles of four-way
races but are there specific states
where as of today given that it is not
quite yet mid-august are there specific
states where a third-party candidate
could be changing the outcome of that
state's decision on november eighth as
to who they will support for President
the answer is absolutely i'm going to
show you now a list of states where gary
johnson helps hillary clinton so this is
a list of states as of today based on
the most recent data from electoral dash
boat dot-com of states were gary johnson
is polling higher then the lead for
Hillary Clinton so here's an example
right in Connecticut Hillary Clinton is
currently up five Gary Johnson is
polling six percent that is a state
where given that Gary Johnson gets more
support from the right than the left
Gary Johnson's presence is clearly
helping Hillary Clinton Florida Clinton
is now plus 2 in Florida Gary Johnson is
polling six percent in Florida Florida
is hugely important a lot of electoral
votes at stake a very important state if
Donald Trump wants to be president Gary
Johnson is directly responsible right
now in part for the fact that Hillary
Clinton is ahead Georgia very few people
would imagine that Georgia's in play
Hillary Clinton currently up five in a
recent poll in Georgia Gary Johnson
polling 9% they're making a difference
Iowa is a tie and Gary Johnson is
polling 12% there Nevada Hillary Clinton
is up one Johnson polling two percent
and then we have both Ohio and Wisconsin
where Gary Johnson is polling ten
percent
bigger than Hillary Clinton's lead if
anybody thinks louis that gary johnson
cannot have an impact at the state level
that list we just showed our TV and
video audience suggests otherwise it's
true uh and uh I were probably both
thinking the same thing that at the same
time this is fantastic and wonderful and
incredible because there's maybe
arguably nothing more important than
introducing more parties to our
political system uh but at the same time
we know what this means for Donald Trump
it's bad for Donald Trump and now i
wanna i don't want to overstate it i
don't want to suggest that Hillary
Clinton might only win if she wins
because of Gary Johnson all of those
states together are a total of ninety
two electoral votes right now if Donald
Trump were to take over a lead in every
single one of those states it would make
it so that he is now projected as the
winner with over 270 electoral votes but
the reality is it's not very likely that
Gary Johnson will ultimately make a
difference in all of these states but
the point is Louis we can point to a
number of states where right now Gary
Johnson support is significantly bigger
than Hillary Clinton's lead and you can
make a pretty strong case that in those
states Gary Johnson's presence is
hurting Trump and helping Hillary which
is exactly what we've said would happen
from day one and I imagine many staunch
Trump supporters are pulling their hair
out right now like we might have been
pulling our hair out yeah when uh when
Ralph Nader did his thing uhhh and so
that's just how it goes but it's it's uh
it's still great that someone who is
running as a third-party can have such
high levels of support and I also want
to be very clear that just because we
can point to individual states were Gary
Johnson appears to be having an impact
the big picture of the map is heavily
influenced by the reality that Hillary
Clinton is quite far ahead right now in
19 of 19 recent polls were Hillary
Clinton not already ahead as the polls
indicate today Gary Johnson's impact
would be smaller so so III don't want to
miss state or be misheard because how
I'm heard is is arguably as important as
what is that I am saying we can point to
some individual states were Gary Johnson
is definitely helping Hillary Clinton
the odds that Gary Johnson based on the
polling today or jill stein reverse the
eventual results in the National
Electoral College on november eighth
pretty pretty slim i've talked about how
people of all ages but particularly
millennials are owning cars less and
participating more in the sharing
economy and one of the more popular
options is zip car which gets you a car
when you want it when you need it they
offer all sorts of cars suvs hybrids
whatever you need it includes insurance
and it includes gas you just pay for the
time that you actually use the car and
you can reserve the car online from your
smartphone over the phone then you
unlock it with your zipcard each car
share member reduces their personal co2
emissions by between 1100 and 1,600
pounds per year for our audience zipcar
is offering $25 a free driving credit if
you sign up at joined zipcar dot-com
slash david support our show reduce your
carbon emissions and you're spending on
cars sign up at join zipcar dot-com
slash david